what's going on reject nation I'm about
to watch the trailer Oh Coco James after
a Conan O'Brien he did a bit about that
neck out and it was way funnier when he
said it not as funny as that all I'm
doing right now is watch this once every
year our ancestors come back to our
world to see family and friends but no
living person
has ever visited their world until now
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
you see with me boy
[Music]
you mind
[Music]
[Music]
anything to declare in my little fact ah
[Music]
[Applause]
oh I live in California so we have a lot
of you know a lot of my friends or
Mexican a lot of people I've dated are
Mexican so that moment okay I don't know
who it out with a woman is who sees
Miguel's like Miguel what is going it
seems accurate to me in Mexican culture
you know it's like this dead relative
sees you alive and it immediately has a
questionable you know disapproving tone
of what the hell are you doing here
goodness not oh my god I'm so happy to
see you but more what are you up to
right now that was really funny I read
about this project of while ago actually
it's from Leon Frick think that's how
you say his name directed Toy Story 3
it's been a long time he's been trying
to get this together isn't trying to get
it done since Toy Story 3 but there was
a lot of issues happening you know this
is inspired by Day of the Dead inspired
by ideas Oh more twists this is junk up
there because I had to like do that take
like six different times because I can't
seem to say do do a mortise and still
not saying the right now I'm not saying
all right Day of the Dead day and I
speak English or I fire by day of the
dentists there's a lot of issues of the
Mexican community and then people from
Pixar Disney we're traveling the next
ago I read the story a while ago kind of
straighten everything out and this has
actually been a passion project of the
directors because the Day of the Dead
has been the thing that's been an
inspiration to is just as imagination
overall for so many years the imagery of
the skeletons and such it looks like
it's honoring it you know I remember one
Mulan came out there are communities in
China that just hated that film because
the film was more like an insult to
Chinese culture and and mock Chinese
culture know a lot of ways I actually
understood it as much as I'm a fan of
the movie Mulan I personally liked it
when I heard that that had happened like
yeah I can see it there pretty much
mocking Chinese culture making fun of it
a good amount of the film and here I'm
going and making fun in the Mexican
culture I feel like they're going to do
whatever they can to make sure they're
really honoring it the imagination reel
does look brought to life and I can't
think of a Pixar film where music played
such a vital part to the experience and
something tells me that the music in
this film is going to be so vital to the
whole movie I wouldn't I wouldn't be
surprised that if by the time this came
out here a lot of critics saying there's
great music in this whole film this
character Miguel he's inspired by this
he idolizes a musician which leads him
into this whole journey of exploring the
afterlife even though the trailers have
never touched on dramatic elements one
thing that a lot of Pixar movies tend to
do well is beyond providing imagination
and a lot of humor a lot of fun is they
could have those real heartbreaking
moments and I can only imagine that for
a story dealing with the afterlife with
his character meaning relatives in the
afterlife that there's going to be some
really heart-wrenching moments really
touching moments moments where he's
probably coming in terms of some things
he never really got to grieve over it's
like uncovering his family's history and
I think that's really cool like thinking
about it in my position if if I were to
meet people in my family history that I
never got to know or didn't get a say
goodbye to or anything along those lines
that would be so fascinating to me to
learn about it from like the ghosts of
my family I was watching this trailer I
was getting chills throughout I was I
was feeling myself being very moved I
have my green goosebumps the whole time
doing everything that picks up the
expect Pixar to do in terms of it being
very beautiful it looks really funny but
you can clearly see there's a major
heart behind it and like I've brought up
earlier I'm hoping that the music
choices in this film the Mexican style
of music is really going to play a big
factor here and I'm hoping that I'm
right that it honors Mexican culture and
doesn't mock it in any capacity because
I also saw like a quick view of the cast
list and one thing that really impressed
me was it seemed like the majority of
the actors were Latino or latina or
Hispanic or you know I don't know the
proper word that won't offend so excuse
me some type of spanish-speaking
language does send it you know what I'm
trying to say I'm not trying to be
offensive it's but it seems like if
they're doing what they can to be
honorable kudos all right guys well
new to the channel you can subscribe and
become a part of the reject nation test
day you can follow me on Instagram and
Twitter at the Greg Alva go check out
our patreon we have a lot of exclusive
perks rewards and video content on there
I'm posting on there like pretty much
throughout the week and it's a lot of
fun I love all you guys I got to go back
to work on a side project with my
brother right now it probably won't be
out for several weeks but when it's out
you will definitely know about it and
I'm more than positive you guys are
going to enjoy know it's not a reaction
something much more special